caroline vous avez un problème oui c'est
un problème sur la nullité sur instagram
on vient de se rendre compte que moins
vous portez des vêtements et plus vous
êtes vous existez sur instagram 1 qui en
soi ok on va le dire on le savait un peu
c'est pas très grave
ce qui est problématique c'est que le
message qu'on envoie à toutes les
petites jeunes filles qui en général ont
13 14 ans sur instagram c'est que en
gros tout ce que tu vas dire ce sera
d'autres le sont moins importants que
ton corps ton body assure et donc plus
plombé d'un eu des plus haut marche sur
les réseaux sociaux
regardez vous dire moi oui vous vous
l'avez fait également regarder ben ali
moi je suis dit regardez regardez mesnil
regarder bnm voilà un peu quand même
c'est pas chaud ça fait cher c'est pas
fou c'est horrible bravo caroline
ithurbide tient à bâle a connu c'est
géraldine maillet
noureddine manaï à l'état isola bella
thorne mine à la main merci à mr dame
chic alors photo le matin c'est tout ma
tête était tout nu à la femme de ton
cousin peu moins à jean michel maire
tient
regardez bah ouais il est beau
franchement tu es très bon ya pas de
filtre voilà voilà les conçoit la ligue
en soi avait pas d'engagement vacants
l'aïe a tous regardé l'eye liner
c'est là qu'il faut faire voilà les
négoces et voilà c'est par occident mais
très peu parlé de nous les crocs et
éventuellement un petit peu à nu oui oui
les chats c'est beau ça il n'y a pas que
nous qui sommes sexy sur les restes de
sa wii aussi ménages laquelle elle a
regardé qu'est-ce qu'elle a pris le bras
gauche morale dégradé progrès si ça va
dégrader progress in albon avait fait
pas notre meilleur exactement alors mais
ça alors c'était un copain mois sans
rigoler jour que c'est vrai nous avons
elle voulait faire un combat contre moi
et pas je lui dirais seulement combattre
contre moi je vais te massacrer n'y a
pas de montage non 0 était vraiment vous
c'est moi c'est malheureux il faut
partir et sont basculées sur les films
d'olivier marchal la france yao k
mentale face et laurent didier lacau pas
moi qui voulais me défier en fait je
vous dis que vous lui montrez y est le
jouet voir ce film je crois vraiment que
toi tu vas me battre voilà mais moi je
ne vous cache pas que ça se voit pas sur
votre petit costume comme ça exemple à
ce point c'est ma cinquième année ces
petits cons c'est vrai j'ai pas bouton
la wii est ce que vous vous êtes donné
la gauche le bras gauche
le bras gauche et c'est hyper dur mais
c'est un coude c'est normal
non tu l'as fait jusque là tu l'as pas
la lune la lutte assez vous fait de la
muscu fait quoi exactement oktar côté je
vais vous dire je fais beaucoup de sport
ça répond pas du ciel quand vous voyez
comme ça là comme ça bien sûr que je me
plaît c'est minimum 15 5 heures de sport
par jour
nantes un malade ou quoi combien minutes
dont dix sérieusement si cette heure par
semaine une fois que la paix n'a pas
dépassé le point dur c'est la preuve
après temps à regarder mais lui il est
magnifique hui je suis en forme mais
aussi s'il est aussi regarder il a fait
du sport il est magnifique elle et j'ai
pris un petit peu la foi de photos l'on
dirait une photo érotique tiré d'un
certain benturki il se passe des choses
vous voyez que le coup